[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
78 bienvenue dans cette émission du
jeudi 26 mars
le coc u19 qui continuent de contaminer
en nombre dans la région selon santé
publique france 962 cas supplémentaires
ont été enregistrés en 24 heures entre
mardi et mercredi au dernier point
publié hier à 14h07 1764 coronavirus
étaient recensés en ile-de-france pour
endiguer la crise sanitaire plusieurs
mesures sont prises quotidiennement
notamment celle de place et elle est
sans abri potentiellement contaminés en
confinement
une cinquantaine de personnes sera
accueilli dès demain à jouy en josas par
arrêté la préfecture des yvelines a
réquisitionné deux bâtiments de l'ancien
site thalès est les sans abris hébergés
présentent tous des suspicions de kovy
de 19 ils seront suivis grâce au
concours de la croix rouge des yvelines
avec des agents d'accueil des
infirmières et des travailleurs sociaux
et l'insee a publié ce jeudi un point
sur la conjoncture liée à la situation
du coc vite 19 la baisse de l'activité
économique est actuellement estimé à 35%
en france situation similaire dans le
département cette crise a un impact sur
plus de 50% de l'activité yvelinoise
interview de gérard bacheliers président
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
des yvelines bonjour gère un bachelier
bonjour président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des yvelines
nous sommes au dixième jour de
confinement la situation économique est
à quasiment à l'arrêt pouvez vous nous
décrire la situation économique globale
1 dans les yvelines
à partir des témoignages que vous avez
des chefs d'entreprise la situation est
plutôt préoccupante actuellement vous
savez que les yvelines c'est un
département qui est industriel donc il
ya deux filières importante l'automobile
et l'aéronautique et l'automobile est à
l'arrêt puis que les deux usines de
poissy et de pleins sont à l'arrêt donc
du coup tous les sous traitants aussi
ont des difficultés veulent justement
pour avoir une activité donc l'activité
des sous traitants et l'aide à 50% à peu
près
pour l'aéronautique les faits et pas
encore sensible mais il le sera par la
suite puisque les commandes d'avions
diminue actuellement et donc qu'il y
aura certainement un effet sensible donc
75% de l'activité donc industrielle dans
les yvelines est arrêté donc est à
l'arrêt ce qui est beaucoup
il ya aussi un domaine qui est qui a eu
qu'à stopper nettement c'est le tourisme
l'activité touristique s'est arrêtée
complètement presque complètement
puisque 90% de l'activité touristique
est à l'arrêt actuellement et au niveau
touristique a beaucoup de sous-traitants
qui dépendent de l'activité touristique
il ya beaucoup de lieux justement
touristiques qui sont aussi utilisés
pour des événements les événements qui
n'ont pas lieu ou qui n'auront pas lieu
qui sont reportés et donc l'événementiel
aussi est touchée donc qu'est
l'événementiel et toucher le btp bien
sûr et touché également la logistique
est également été touchées donc il ya
beaucoup d'activités bien sûr bien sûr
l'hôtellerie-restauration et le commerce
qui avait déjà eu à gérer des baisses
sensibles les derniers mois avoir la
crise sanitaire
avez vous des chiffres sur le nombre de
commerces qui ont dû fermer parce que le
gouvernement leur demandes et 55 % des
commerces endurant dû fermer dans les
yvelines ce qui représente donc à 8000
8000 entreprises 40 mille salariés
et puis un certain nombre de commerces
qui n'avait pas l'obligation de fermer
ont quand même fermé parce que sur les
manques et de salariés soit pour des
problèmes sanitaires ils n'ont pas voulu
ouvrir donc en particulier les grandes
surfaces de bricolage certaines grandes
surfaces de bricolage n'ont pas ouvert
les garages sont ouverts un quart des
garages seulement sont ouverts donc vous
voyez que non seulement
il ya ceux qui ont été obligés de fermer
mais ceux qui ont fermé malgré tout et
puis dans 75 % du coût de l'activité des
commerces à baisser dans les yvelines et
la fermeture des marchés va pas arranger
les choses à pour les artisans dans le
domaine justement d'alimentation et des
produits de bouche
est ce que vous êtes optimiste sur
l'avenir est ce que les entreprises vont
fermer
est-ce qu'il ya déjà des dépôts de bilan
est ce que vous êtes plutôt optimiste
pessimiste il ya entre les deux je
dirais que la crise est quand même
importante et des entreprises était déjà
fragile avant ces crises sanitaires donc
il est évident qu'elle sert nombre
d'entreprises dans disparaître ça c'est
inévitable simplement nous devons
essayer toutes les partenaires qui
aident les entreprises justement essayer
de les aider à passer cette crise les
dispositifs qui ont été mises en place
par à la fois l'état et la région sont
quand même important moi je conseille
aux entreprises de les utiliser lors
qu'ils rentrent dans les critères et
aussi d'utiliser les prêts bancaires qui
permettent justement de passer cette
phase de trésorerie éventuellement
difficile ça devrait leur permettre
justement de passer 6 mois 9 mois
hélas après la crise est là que les la
situation va être la plus grave
justement et c'est là qu'on doit
apporter le maximum d'informations et
des doses entrepris du territoire si
vous êtes chef d'entreprise la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie d'île de
france a mis en place une cellule de
crise le numéro et l'adresse mail
s'affiche en bas de l'écran trente
conseillers sont à votre écoute dans les
yvelines un accompagnement et du conseil
dans la gestion de cette crise et les
démarches à effectuer pour bénéficier
des aides de l'état
justement le gouvernement a pris des
décisions à destination des entreprises
objectif faire face aux difficultés
économiques est des annonces la semaine
dernière puis deux textes de lois votées
en urgence par les parlementaires ont
fait le point avec nicolas d'andré
première mesure le recours au chômage
partiel face à la réduction à l'arrêt
obligatoire de l'activité de votre
entreprise vous pouvez demander de
placer vos salariés ans
activité partielle en clair l'état prend
en charge le paiement des horaires non
travaillés et à hauteur de 84 % du
salaire net
jusqu'à la limite de 4,5 smic dans les
yvelines d'après les premières tendances
de la direccte entre le 1er janvier et
le 24 mars 2020 près de 1300 entreprises
ont déposé une demande que ça concerne
environ trente deux mille salariés et
pour comparaison sur la même période en
2010 9 78 société avait fait la demande
pour 12000 personnes à propos de ce
dispositif vous pouvez contacter la
direccte ile de france ou retrouver des
informations sur son site internet
deuxième disposition le report du
paiement des cotisations sociales et des
impôts des entreprises
une demande a réalisé auprès de l'urssaf
ou sur le site internet impots.gouv.fr
autres mesures la mise en place d'une
garantie de crédit c'est à dire que
l'état peut se porter garant d'un crédit
pour une entreprise
acteur majeur de ce dispositif la bpi
france informations à retrouver aussi
sur son site internet
et il ya aussi la possibilité de ré
échelonner son crédit en cours avec la
médiation du crédit
enfin quatrième dispositif à destination
des petites entreprises des micro
entrepreneurs des indépendants ou encore
des professions libérales l'état met en
place une aide de 1500 euros pour des
structures ayant moins d'un million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires ayant subi
une fermeture administrative et
connaissant une perte de chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 70% par rapport à
la même période l'an dernier
autre initiative lancée par l'état qui
concerne un secteur en particulier celui
de l'agriculture impacté par des mesures
de confinement et des exploitants qui
manquent de bras en ce moment le
gouvernement vient d'annoncer le
lancement d'une plateforme en ligne pour
les personnes qui souhaiteraient
apporter leur aide aux agriculteurs
proches de chez eux ils devront s'y
inscrire pour des missions de récoltes
de fruits et légumes des semis à du
printemps une activité qui sera rétribué
le ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume a confirmé que des contrats de
travail encadrerait la pratique et
pourrait se cumuler avec du chômage
partiel et des minima sociaux
d'après le syndicat agricole de la fnsea
quarante mille personnes se seraient
déjà à manille
testé depuis mardi est la plateforme
sera mise en ligne à partir de demain
vendredi
en complément des mesures prises par
l'état les collectivités viennent aussi
en aide aux entreprises situées sur leur
territoire c'est le cas de la région ile
de france qui a mis en place un plan
d'urgence
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines elle est aussi sur le pont
othman nassr ou conseillère régionale et
vice président de l'agglomération nous
explique et les actions menées report
d'un certain nombre de crédits qui peut
être fait est là dessus la région
apporte sa garantie aux prêts bancaires
en lien avec mes pays francesca hauteur
de garanties qu'il demande à 90%
on venir à la fois évidemment soulagé
entreprises qui ont des crédits sur des
traîneaux prix tendues depuis aussi leur
permettre évidemment de passer ce moment
et elles ont besoin de s'endetter à
nouveau pour financer le fond de
roulement s'est évidemment leurs bêtes
actuelle l'objectif c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas de fallait donner le moins possible
[Musique]
yardi spécifique pour les très petites
entreprises et pour l entreprise
individuelle avec un financement qui
aimante et y avait qu un fonds d'urgence
qui a été mis en place en lien avec le
temps que la région abonde massivement
et il a obligé aussi qu'on puisse les
aider à passer ce qu'on dit il alors
évidemment c'est alex de ne pas être
suffisant ce qui veut dire et c'est pour
cela que j'invite tous les acteurs
économiques à jouer leur rôle et surtout
à regarder l'ensemble des dispositifs
qui existent parce que chez me bukavu
canton et qui vivent ensemble l'esprit
mais on peut espérer rythme atténué les
effets de cette crise dont on ne sait
pas aujourd'hui combien de temps elle va
durer
[Musique]
j'ai pris la décision en tant que
président de la plaignante est molle de
suspendre le paiement des loyers
là aussi provenir soulager les
trésoreries de la centaine de sociétés
aujourd'hui installé au sein de la
pépinière d'entreprises de prendre paul
parce que c'est à dire pour nous
évidemment de leur éternel leur
permettre de passer ce moment il on peut
le faire on va là aujourd'hui une bonne
santé financière et l'agglomération et a
pris des munitions du même type exemple
notre fonds de prêts d'honneur
initiative à quentin jean michel petit
la crise il ya des millions de suspendre
le remboursement des prêts pour les
entreprises qui en bénéficient l'appui
de ce fonds elles sont nombreuses
face à cette conjoncture économique et
l'inquiétude règne chez les chefs
d'entreprise une crainte justifiée par
l'ampleur de la crise sanitaire qui
entraîne l arrêt des activités
économiques dans une majorité de
sociétés
écoutez le président du medef civile les
chefs d'entreprise sont mobilisés our
permettent alors alors salle à leurs
collaborateurs de continuer à travailler
pour ceux qui sont autorisés à le faire
à utiliser principalement le télétravail
quand c'est possible et quand c'est
impossible bas il incite effectivement
leurs collaborateurs à se présenter à
leur poste
ça se passe dans des conditions de
discussions de concertations parce que
si les salariés se présenta au travail
il ya effectivement des consignes de
protection à respecter et nous sommes
déterminés à ce que l'activité
économique ne soit pas totalement à
l'arrêt mais qu'elle continue bien sûr
dans des conditions de sécurité maximale
quels sont les effets les inquiétudes
les principales inquiétudes ressenties
par les chefs d'entreprise les
principales inquiétudes vous savez quand
une entreprise est à l'arrêt elle puise
dans ses dans sa trésorerie
et si ya pas de chiffres c'est la
trésorerie d'entreprise qui permet à
l'entreprise de répondre à ces
à ses besoins en termes de factures en
termes de salaires en termes de charge
en termes d'impôts etc etc
la quiétude si vous voulez c'est comment
ça va se passer
notamment pour ceux qui veulent faire
bénéficier le salarié du chômage partiel
comment ça va se passer pour régler les
taxes et les charges qui arrive
comment ça va se passer avec les banques
parce qu'il va falloir aller chercher du
financement pour répondre aux besoins
actuels
bien entendu les investissements
d'aujourd'hui sont un arrêt parce que on
ne pas qu'on n'a plus de projet aux gens
d'une autre projet c'est de voir un peu
ce qui se passe et attendre la reprise
de l'activité
dernière question zakaria redit temps la
reprise aura lieu est ce que vous serez
vous êtes plutôt optimiste pour la
reprise ou pas du tout écoutez moi je
peux vous dire une chose c'est mon
sentiment personnel
legault l'état ne pourra pas sauver tout
le monde et c'est pourquoi nous invitons
toutes les parties que ça soit
entrepreneurs chefs d'entreprise
salariés à ce que l'activité en france
ne s'arrête pas il ne faut pas paralyser
la france parce que la reprise et le
redémarrage va être extrêmement
difficile maintenant je ne veux pas
donner un message d'inquiétude et
d'angoissé ou jouer le pessimiste
forcené j'y crois parce que nous avons
des collaborateurs motivés
nous avons des collaborateurs qui
veulent que l'entreprise continue la
reprise va être difficile parce que le
les entreprises vont fonctionner sur
leurs enfants trésorerie elles vont
solliciter des aides financières
nous verrons donc elles mesurent toutes
ces aides que l'état a mis en place vont
suffire vont fonctionner vont permettre
la reprise et le redémarrage de la
économique en est au contraire le début
de la crise sanitaire a pu profiter à
certains secteurs comme les magasins de
matériels et services informatiques qui
font partie des commerces autorisés à
rester ouverts pendant le confinement
est la pme fcb informatique à une
boutique notamment à coignières a connu
par exemple un pic d'activité la semaine
dernière le reportage de nicolas landry
et de patrick jacques de dixmude lundi
16 mars veille du confinement ses
bureaux étaient pleins les
collaborateurs de cette pme spécialisée
dans le matériel et la maintenance
informatique était sur le pont en une
journée cette entreprise a réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires normalement réalisé
sur une semaine énormément de
d'entreprises qui ne s'était pas du tout
préparés au confinement by normand de
demandes entreprises pour mettre en
place des accès distants des réseaux
pour s'équiper en ordinateurs portables
mais aussi en webcam un micro casque
dans cette zone commerciale c'est le
seul commerce à avoir l'autorisation
d'être ouvert l'activité de cette pme se
poursuit elle continue à recevoir des
clients notamment ce chef d'entreprise
pas notre client a besoin de faire du
télétravail est donc en fait on va lui
fournir un écran supplémentaire pour
pouvoir connecter son ordinateur
portable est en fait avoir deux écrans
pour faire justement toutes les tâches
administratives là en urgence je viens
chercher du matériel en complément et
j'ai mes bureaux qui sont à côté aux
essarts-le-roi où je bosse à distance
tout seul pour pouvoir faire avancer mon
entreprise tant qu'elle peut avancer
maintenant sur site il ya deux personnes
à notre magasin de versailles et deux
personnes dont moi même ici à coignières
pour servir les clients qui ont des
pannes qui ont besoin de webcams de
casques l'ordinateur portable ou faire
réparer leur matériel depuis le
confinement la majorité des salariés
sont en télétravail durant cette
première semaine beaucoup d'activités
entre 100 à 150 demandes quotidiennes de
télémaintenance
chaque jour est différent et on va voir
la semaine prochaine
comment on va s'organiser pour maintenir
donc une continuité d'activité mais
aussi adapter les équipes à la demande
pour le moment l'activité se maintient
mais si la crise se poursuit sur
plusieurs mois
cette pme pourrait connaître des
conséquences plus lourdes
sortons de l'anglais économique
à présent la pandémie de coronavirus et
le confinement qui en résultent impacte
considérablement votre vie vous nous
partager depuis quelques jours vos
vidéos n'hésitez pas à continuer
d'ailleurs certains journalistes de la
rédaction aussi sont confinés chez eux
troisième témoignage ce soir avec
aurélien pas forcément vous en coûtera
le quotidien fait un petit peu
bouleversé a notamment quand on a deux
enfants nos enfants en plus en plus
souvent en bas âge que le petit a
discrètement il est il est en crèche à
la grande à 50 me elle est en grande
section maternelle on voit là cet âge là
on s'est pas forcément s'occuper tout
seul alors heureusement pour l'aîné il
ya sa maîtresse qui nous envoie tous les
matins les devoirs à faire et mine de
rien en grande section de maternelle est
quand même pas mal de petits exercices à
faire notamment ce ne serait ce que que
la date en fait du jour voilà écrire la
date du jour même pour nous j'ai envie
de dire sa douceur parce qu'on sait plus
trop quel jour on est avec voilà avec ce
ce confinement
donc voilà pas mal de petits exercices à
faire lors le bémol bien sûr c'est comme
pas mal voilà deux personnes qui vivent
en région parisienne là je suis je suis
dans un appartement
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué pour
les normalement les temps de récréation
alors bien sûr heureusement j'ai la
chance d'avoir un petit bal couronnes 1
m sur 6 voilà c'est quand même pas
suffisant pour la grande phase de la
trottinette
on met du coup voilà bah on fait du
ballon dans les dents dans le couloir
par exemple voilà puisque la maîtresse
ou dit qu'il faut à peu près 30 minutes
et d'activité physique
et puis alors le manque aussi pour
notamment je pense pour les enfants qui
sont qui sont à l'école n'a cessé les
copains et les copines en nous ce qu'on
a fait par exemple c'est qu'on a créé
sur sur bois de sapin groupe justement
avec tous les tous les parents et tous
les jours du coup on envoie des photos
nos enfants voilà pour qu'ils puissent
se voir et pu maintenir un petit peu ce
ce lien entre voilà avant la reprise ça
aussi c'est la grande question savoir
maman quand est-ce que l'école va
rouvrir
voilà on essaie d'expliquer avec avec
des mots simples voilà qui vaut mieux
rester chez soi pour pas pour pas être
malade et puis surtout pour pas voilà
véhicule et le virus donc voila tout se
passe bien tout cas de mon côté on sait
pas encore étriqués et vous aussi
n'hésitez pas à nous partager vos
témoignages c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale merci de l'avoir suivi
on se quitte sur ces images pour
clôturer cette édition spéciale
grandement consacrée à l'impact
économique du coronavirus dans les
yvelines des enseignes aux rideaux
baissés des parkings vides dans la zone
commerciale des portes de cheuvreux à
coignières rester à la maison et belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]